Have you wondered what it would be like to be an astronaut floating around in the space station?
Why are the astronauts floating?
I'm here at the powerhouse museum in sydney to find out if anyone knows the answer
Why are they floating in their gravity in our graphic zero-gravity there's my gravity's
The stuff that holds us to the planet Brumis beam doesn't happen up there gravity holds you the answer in space. There's nothing there
[they] just float. There's no gravity in space
hey there if your seeing this right now then you have found my secret code
No greater. That's very little but is there really no gravity in eat my ass oh yeah
After all the moon orbits the Earth due to gravitational attraction
So where with the space station fit in this picture?
Can you make me a roughly to scale?
Model of the Earth and the Moon and then we're [gonna] position the space station in there, so [try] like that
Maybe then you ready to see the real distance hMM. How do you reckon oh?
It's actually about
here maybe a little further
I think we were wrong now if the moon is here and the Earth is there whereabouts would you put the space station?
Yeah pity
About halfway yeah right about here
So [that's] maybe like a quarter of the distance to the [moon] let me show you the real distance you ready for the real distance
The space Station is right about there
The space Station is actually only about [four] [hundred] [kilometers] away, so if you're in Sydney
It's a little further than the drive to Canberra, but does it make sense that the earth exerts a big gravitational force on you?
But nothing on the astronauts just a short distance away, you reckon there be no gravity there
There's not much. They [flex] we've seen them. Well clearly there's not [they're] floating [around]
I know they float and the question is why no idea
Well in truth the force on the astronauts is almost as much as the force on you
So then why are they floating while you're stuck here the answer is the astronauts aren't floating they're falling
and not only that but the space station, they're in is falling as well ah
So why doesn't the [space] [station] come crashing into the Earth?
Well the reason is the space station and astronauts inside have this huge sideways velocity of about
[28,000] kilometers per hour
So even though they're falling towards the [earth] they're going so fast that as they fall towards the Earth's surface
It curves away from them
If the Earth didn't put a gravitational force on them, they would fly out into space sure yeah, right
So it's due to that gravitational pull that they can actually keep orbiting the Earth
If it was to stop moving, and it would be plummeting exactly, what would they?
They would still feel weightless until you smash into something
So the space station and the astronauts inside are constantly accelerating towards the Earth's core
but they never get any closer and
Because they're accelerating at the same rate the astronauts feel weightless they have this amazing
sensation of floating
you